this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
okay I'll admit it I was pleasantly
surprised by The Witcher interesting
characters compelling narratives and new
takes on an old genre but then I got to
this part - the Sentra then I come to
claim what is rightfully mine perfecta
by the law of surprise oh cool the law
of surprise that thing
wait the the what now and then a number
of thoughts went through my head okay
Devin you went to law school this is
clearly a lot this is a thing you know
this think Devin law school contracts
offer acceptance law of surprise think
you don't want Thomas Frank to make fun
of you again wait there's no such thing
as the law of surprise is there it was
an emotional couple of moments hey legal
eagles it's time to think like a lawyer
because I'm trying to figure out the
witcher and if i have to do it then by
god i'm taking you with me
the witcher is the newest entree into
the fantasy genre and eight episodes
series on Netflix for those who are
still going through Game of Thrones
withdrawal the show is based on a set of
short stories published by Polish author
Andrzej Sapkowski and also gave rise to
the famous Witcher video games as well
the main plot centers around a few main
characters the central protagonist
Geralt of Rivia the eponymous Witcher
the mage yennefer of vengerberg and
princess cirilla their lives are
intertwined for a variety of reasons
most of which are tied to the vague
concept of destiny
destiny has determined the surprise be
better if you're unfamiliar with the
books then the show itself can be a
little bit confusing based on the
different roles between The Witcher
elves mages and there's a lot to absorb
and understand but possibly none are
more confusing and controversial than
the witcher's law of surprise the law of
surprise is introduced in episode 4 of
The Witcher when during a soiree also
they refer to this party as a soiree
many times and the
French neologism seems way out of place
at any rate during this soiree the point
is to find a suitor for Queen Clancy's
daughter pavetta and during the course
of these suitors trying to woo pavetta
helmeted man Dooney comes in claiming
that the Queen's daughter is actually
owed to him due to his right under the
law of surprise I am Lord Aegean of
Allen world and I have come to claim
your daughter's hand in marriage he
claims to have earned this right by
saving life of the Queen's late husband
King raga nor my whole life living
misery until the day that I say to your
husband King raga know from a certain
death by tradition
I trust the lure of surprises payment
Dooney or the night of perche own
demands his payment in the form of
pavetta is hand in marriage
but don't worry this isn't rapey because
they conveniently already met and fell
in love off-screen in Canada probably so
pavetta is what lawyers would call his
chattel property until destiny
intervened and our hearts collided but
also girl power
I guess so despite the me2 issues with
the law of surprise on its face the law
is relatively straightforward for
payment of a great deed usually saving
someone's life one can claim something
which the debtor does not yet possess at
the moment the law is claimed it's a
surprise for the giver and the receiver
the tricky part is there appears to be
two possible outcomes for the one
invoking the law of surprise they will
receive either the first thing that
comes to greet the indebted when they
return home after their life is being
saved or what you find at home and you
don't expect Geralt is apparently super
cool with this arranged marriage /
indentured servitude and when given the
chance to repay Dooney for saving his
life he claims the same right regarding
pavetta and thus the circle of slavery
continues with pavetta child ciri being
contracted to Geralt people may well
always find each other feminism so those
are the terms of the law of surprise but
is it legal let's take a look at the
legal enforceability of the law of
surprise as if it were applied today in
the usually non fantasy world that we
live in now right off the bat we can see
that there is a huge problem when
dealing with any law that allows one to
acquire another person as a designated
method of payment as you probably know
the Thirteenth Amendment states neither
slavery nor involuntary servitude except
as punishment for crime whereof the
party shall have been duly convicted
shall exist within the United States or
any subject to their jurisdiction so
considering in both instances that we
see on-screen in The Witcher the law of
surprises invoke to claim the daughter
of one who was saved it appears that
this would clearly be a violation of the
Thirteenth Amendment against
involuntary servitude now sure pavetta
seemed perfectly content with being
given over to Dooney since they had
already fallen in love conveniently but
I've got to imagine that that's more of
the
exception rather than the rule clearly
the Witcher has no problem with
involuntary servitude a promise made
must be on it but Bill of Rights
SMIL of Rights let's think beyond the
Constitution what if we assume that the
law of surprised resulted in the
transfer for something other than humans
maybe a new puppy a pup as ice-t--
refers to it or a new car that your
significant other bought for you while
you were away with the law of surprise
be legal then well to answer this
question it would require a foray into
the complicated world of contract law
and just as the delightful yeah skier
says respect doesn't make history well
contract law probably doesn't make for
great fantasy fiction but let's take a
look and see how we might make a
workable law of surprise in real life
now by way of background contract law
unlike some other areas of law like
criminal law is not really codified into
a bunch of neatly packaged statutes
contract law is primarily developed from
the common law
there's no swindler asking for payment
with the law surprises as old as mankind
itself generally contract law is a blend
of State case law that's developed by
judges and statutes that are passed by
state legislatures so first things first
how is a contract formed well in order
for there to be a contract there are
certain requirements that or elements
that have to be met and while it varies
a little bit from state to state
generally those are an offer an
acceptance of that offer consideration
between the parties mutuality of
obligation competency and capacity and
in certain circumstances though
certainly not all or even most
circumstances a written instrument a
written contract so let's begin with the
offer an offer for purposes of contract
law is a promise to do or refrain from
doing something specific in the future
an offer can be as simple as party a
offers to MOU party B's lon
next Tuesday so in the case of The
Witcher right off the bat it's hard to
see how the law of surprise even meets
the first element of contract formation
in that it doesn't contain a valid offer
it's more like a gratuitous gift
essentially half of the exchange is
already accomplished for example King
Ragan ORS life is already saved by
Dooney so that there's no reason for a
contract to be formed in order for
payment because nothing was offered in
the first place now on the other hand
just because the parties don't expressly
exchange words it's still possible that
based on their actions something known
as an implied in fact contract has
occurred an implied in fact contract is
an obligation rising from a mutual
agreement and intent to promise where
the agreement and the promise haven't
actually been expressed in words that
regardless of the means of expressing
the contract implied in fact contract
still requires an unambiguous offer
acceptance and mutual intent to be bound
and of course consideration but here we
run into the same problems the deed has
already been done the life has been
saved under circumstances that don't
give rise to a contract or an implied
contract so we still have the same
problems but for the sake of argument
let's consider the fact that we're
calling this the law of surprise so in
this fictional scenario the law of
surprise was passed by a governing body
and codified into a statute and thus no
offer or acceptance is required merely a
life being saved requires payment in
return so for the sake of argument let's
assume that the I don't know legislature
Parliament of sintra has passed this law
of surprise and it doesn't require offer
or acceptance in terms of these
circumstances where you save a life
let's move on to the third element
that's required for a contract to be
formed and that's consideration and
consideration is generally described as
promising something of value in exchange
for a specified action or non action of
another person essentially value for
value so if you agree to give a gift to
someone that's not a contract because
you have gratuitously offered something
to them and received no consideration
back for your promise and if that's the
case that might actually work you
obviously have performed something of
great value you saved someone's life and
that is extremely valuable to the
persons whose life was saved and in
return you were being promised to this
other thing you don't know what it is
but it might be something of great value
and the law allows for you to contract
for something is valueless as a they
call it a peppercorn yes it's a very
very low value but its value nonetheless
and you are allowed to contract based on
that mutual exchange so this law of
surprise actually kind of works in terms
of consent
raishin but that raises another problem
which is that often a defense to a
contract is vagueness or ambiguity and
here's where things really start to get
dicey courts require what's called a
meeting of the minds to form a contract
that means that the parties agree to
what the terms of the contract are and
if we look back at the law of surprise
we see that the thing that is being
promised is either the first thing that
comes to greet the debtor when they
return home after their life is being
saved or what they find at home and
didn't expect so in a word that sounds
ambiguous now on the other hand every
contract involves some risk let's say
you formed a contract for the farmer to
buy their entire crop for the year you
might get a huge bumper crop or you
might get nothing because the crop was
wiped out because of a drought so
there's always an inherent risk in some
ambiguity in terms of performance but
this also seems like you have no idea
what you're contracting for in the first
place on top of that there's overall
ambiguity as to how this contract would
be enforced even the specific words used
in the law of surprise like greet or the
the time frame that we're talking about
here could be open to multiple
interpretations what does it mean to be
greeted with something when you get home
what if the first thing that happens is
your dog runs out and looks you in the
face what if your spouse is angry with
you and starts yelling at you what if
there are multiple things that are new
that you didn't expect when you got home
what if there are twins do you oh both
of them or just one the options and
interpretations are endless I feel like
at the very least everyone in this
fictional world of The Witcher needs a
good lawyer to talk about all of these
different eventualities and then of
course we run into huge performance
issues in contract law generally your
damages are measured in money sometimes
you're entitled to what's called
specific performance or in other words
compelling one party to turn over the
other for example that happens a lot in
real estate where a piece of real estate
is considered so unique that money
damages are not enough to compensate
someone for the loss of that property
that was supposed to be turned over and
if we are talking about money damages
for a person that was promised and
doesn't want to go through with the
indentured servitude how
supposed to value that person's life in
daylight's and sunsets in Midnight's or
cups of coffee basically impossible to
put a value on that person and there's
at least one other contract defense that
would probably bar a law of surprise
contract from being formed we just
called the statute of frauds now I
mentioned earlier that most contracts
actually don't need to be written that
is a common misconception you can have
an oral contract as long as you meet the
other requirements for contract
formation but the law requires that
certain contracts do in fact be written
down the idea is that certain contracts
are so important that to prevent fraud
we need to require a written document
now the types of contracts to which this
defense applies our contracts often that
involve the sale or transfer of land
contracts that cannot be completed
within one year and those made in
connection with marriage and two of
those scenarios could be argued by a
defendant in challenging the
enforceability of the law of surprise
certainly the example of Dooney and
pavetta highlights both of these
contract types
Dooney didn't claim the law of surprise
for pavetta until 15 years after the
contract was made I knew no woman would
ever accept me like this so I waited I
waited until the 12th Bell when the
curse breaks and on top of that Duty is
claiming that his contract entitles him
to marry pavetta based on the law of
surprise and thus we have a legitimate
defense that under the statute of frauds
that this contract was required to be in
writing and it wasn't now is there any
way that we could revise this law of
surprise in order to make a legally
binding contract well I think so but
there are a couple of things that we
need to address first we have the
ambiguity problem so we need to get rid
of this you're entitled to whatever it
is that the debtor finds upon returning
home instead of saying it's whatever
they find at the time of contract
formation you say I want in return for
saving your life
this specific thing your new car your
horse your newborn pup by specifying the
things that you are entitled to you
remove a lot of the ambiguity on top of
that in
order to solve the problem of offer and
acceptance instead of claiming the law
of surprise after you save someone's
life you might want to say before you
save their life yes I will in fact save
your life but only if you promise me X Y
or Z by proactively doing it in a sort
of underhanded way they are promising to
give you that thing in return for your
consideration of saving their life
obviously something of great value and
of course leave the women out of it
you can't contract for people now of
course this kind of takes the surprise
out of the law of surprise but I mean I
don't know what you want for me no one
ever spoke to their lawyer and was like
I love talk to my lawyer they let me do
whatever I want
so yeah the law of surprise as its
portrayed in The Witcher has more legal
holes in it than Swiss cheese certainly
if someone brought a breach of contract
case based on the law of surprise the
court would strike down that contract is
invalid on any number of grounds but
based on some minor adjustments the law
of surprise might give rise to a valid
contract but if we've learned anything
from The Witcher it's that we should
appreciate those who roam the land
looking to right wrongs and do justice
and I think you know who I'm talking
about
so if you could please toss a coin to
your lawyer
Oh website of plenty no website of
plenty
II toss a coin to your lawyer
a friend of legality
[Music]
now I bet you didn't think I play guitar
and you're kind of right because I
barely play guitar I've been meaning to
brush up on my skills and I've been
meaning to take Mike Boyd Skillshare
class guitar fundamentals learn quick
with Mike Boyd in this class Mike walks
you through the basics of learning to
play guitar starting with the guitar
anatomy leading all the way up to
playing your first two songs even if
you've never played a guitar in your
life Mike Boyd will show you what you
need to know or if you want to learn
another skill check out Mike's other
skill share course how to learn
strategies for starting practicing and
mastering the skills you've always
wanted which helps anyone learn
something new reduce their likelihood of
quitting a new challenge or get good at
something faster Skillshare is an online
learning community that has tens of
thousands of classes on everything like
music design technology and business
it's great for anyone who wants to learn
guitar or basically any other skill that
you can think of a yearly membership is
less than ten dollars per month but the
first 500 legal eagles will get two free
months of skill share when you click on
the link below plus clicking on the link
really helps out the channel so just
click the link in the description a free
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topic so you can improve your
skills and learn new things all free for
two months those girls will be rewarded
so do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all my other legal reactions including
my take on South Park and the Simpsons
and I promise it features none of my
singing or guitar playing and as always
I'll see you in court
you